umgangsformen 4.0 tipps von professor
thomas schäfer elmayer heute
tischmanieren tisch mal wir sind
natürlich ein sehr umfangreiches kapitel
aber einige wichtige tipps dazu ganz
unangenehm ist es wenn leute mit vollem
mund sprechen wenn wir also eine frage
gestellt wird und ich haben und noch
voll dann sollte ich zuerst einmal
runterschlucken und dann erst antworten
dann gibt es natürlich verschiedene
regeln zum verhalten bei besteck wenn
ich sehr viel besteht habe links und
rechts mehrere garnituren dann beginnt
man immer von außen nach innen
man sollte praktisch auch aufrecht
sitzen und den löffel oder die gabel zum
mund führen und nicht den bund in
richtung keller hinunter beugen
außerdem ist natürlich bei tisch auch
die regel wer sich zuerst hin setzt
dabei hilft der herr seiner dame beim
platznehmen oder auch wenn sie
zwischendurch oder zum schluss wieder
aufsteht indem er ihr beim sesselrücken
behilflich ist
weitere tipps und infos zum thema
tischmanieren erfährt er im buch von
professor thomas schäfer elmayer der
große elmayer